I always had a good relationship with
them and then once the midterm election
happened he started taking shots at me I
didn't really do anything to do it
except do a good job but that's fine I
mean Sean you know when you're making
things happen you take incoming from a
variety of targets so that's just the
nature of the business and I'm happy to
I'm happy to stand strong and do what's
right this is such a weak answer by the
standards of what Republican voters want
DeSantis isn't wrong listen DeSantis is
accurately pointing out
he used to like me then he stopped
liking me when it became clear that
DeSantis wasn't backing down from
challenging Trump in 2024. this is how
it all started remember that what
happened was DeSantis was asked
would you consider
running in 2024 and would you commit to
only doing it if Trump isn't running and
DeSantis didn't rule out now I might run
even if Trump trump runs I might
challenge Trump this was seen as
disloyal